okay so where were these episodes before
these episodes no good job no yeah you
know what though um here's what I
realize
skeletons in the closet oh that's this
episode ah I now see what they were
trying to do with this answer somewhere
to Avatar they're trying to sort of
create sort of the innocent fun side of
the character so that when they're
thrown into the real you can just
focus totally on the real going on
like the real the big action the big
climax and all that stuff start working
a little bit more like a one big movie
um and you know for me it was just like
I didn't think they did that too great
but or not as good a dancer as avatar at
least but yeah now that we're getting
into all this stuff I mean it's like
half of this story is just the backstory
of these two characters and these two
brothers and it's such a good backstory
I mean it's like wow is this good now
good unbend your brother Jesus you know
with you you know when that when the
puppet master episode aired and everyone
was talking about it yeah it wasn't it
creepy I was like yeah yeah the idea is
more creepy but I'm saying I get it it's
still family you show so you sir have to
keep restraint here
they threw in the element of the family
in there too and blood pain the family
in the control of the Father and that's
just an extra level to add whether that
uncomfortableness what a douchebag
yeah I know I know that hold that whole
backstory gets me every time I watch it
that's the one moment where I'm just
like Jesus Christ you know and the a you
know in damnation do it when the brother
is bending the Wolves I mean God the
animation this whole flashback is
unbelievable just the look on his face
is so intense and the way they draw
these animals I mean being so helpless
they believe it's a moon like I'm like
you've never seen them on space yet and
I'm like that's him yeah you totally get
it you told me what's real the the
reveal that aman and
tarrlok our brothers did did not shock
me because at first I thought maybe
tarrlok was Amon but then did you start
getting a lot more it's like you know
well cuz they sound very similar then
when not and then you know that one can
blood Benoit in any way depending they
have to be connected I didn't think it
was just because I thought that was too
obvious I'm like and they would have
kept this a better secret and it looks
like it's pointing towards them really
easily so well but particularly when
they meet up and he takes the bending
away there's this okay so if they're not
working for each other they have to be
somehow these do have to be connected
that both can do something that nobody
else can do and they've learned how to
do it you know you did that's quite a
coincidence so you know having a be
siblings was a good idea um I just love
stories about I don't know what it is
about best friends or siblings or you
know these relationships where they just
they start all so close but then they go
awry and this weapon do you I
whatever competition later and yeah I
just love those kind of stories and I
think this one is just like one of the
best at me because you have the
connection with the father to him the
game the father's backstory so well and
that was they dead can another episode
do it it it tied it all together it did
like like because I was the whole issue
with tarrlok I remember watching it the
first time and I'm like well that was a
fun detour but what the hell and then
when we got to this episode I was like
oh you actually tied all of this
together yeah brilliant
I obviously it was one of those is just
like avatar you know well maybe it'll
come back later yeah I mean that like I
said that's always the stuff I learned
it's like okay let's I'll have my
opinion now but it's like I just keep in
mind just wait wait let's see let's see
and maybe the fart bending will be
phenomenal maybe they'll find a way to
tie it in it'll be like wow that was the
secret to everything
fart bending what a tweest who knows but
no oh well spoiler god thanks for
ruining that room but yeah the only the
other thing that's kind of interesting
well first of all I they're more and
more utilizing I forget
real guys name but just always call them
Ford because obviously it's supposed to
be you know is sort of like been before
word with the way he makes everything
and it was stopped
is that okay that's not gonna be yeah
sorrow and sorrow coming out with the
planes I love that they have that guy
because then you can introduce new
mechanics I know some fans Sato yeah
actually Sato they know I like that all
about realism that's a soft teeth yeah
so so say don't when he has these planes
come out and they're just like you know
what what is that what is that sound you
know what that sound is but at the same
time you're like oh they're in
trouble and it's just a great
anticipation having no other tanks drink
them I love it well it's when that fleet
just sails in and there's nothing there
yeah that's like a serious moment what's
going on here Dante Basco way that only
you can do like you're just like I don't
get it
just something doesn't feel right and
you just feel that sense of dread of
just seriously know what is going on
here it's a trap yeah um and then the
whir of the airplanes and that was a
great shot yeah it is usually coming in
yeah you sure went on the fast or that
shaky-cam quote you know zoom in sort of
thing but that was really a bogans line
where is he finding all this time to
make more evil um so you know the one
thing you brought up at whichever I talk
about uh which is interesting is the
design of I row you know I wrote okay or
whatever I got to be very careful here
because I do not want this okay let me
start off by saying I know what you're
gonna say you gotta keep going I think
Dante Bosco is a fantastic voice actor
one of the best out there and this is
not on him so I want this out there like
just this has nothing to do with him not
turning in a great performance this is a
great performance and we were watching
this and applauding like this yeah the
issue is the character design on the
actual character the art design looks to
me like if you crossed guests on
Prince Charming with every disease and
this is the problem is that sort of
character design whenever you see that
generally your thought is you're going
to get the Gaston deep booming you know
why hello and when Dante Bosco's voice
comes out of it I have a hard time like
like viewing those two things together
like hearing that boys come out of that
character design I just say what no
here's the thing is that Dante Bosco has
this very unique voice who he completely
owns I mean this is a guy who is I mean
he just completely owned this boys and I
can't get enough of it yeah and may it's
so powerful I even than this it's like
oh my god you are a completely new care
if you've been in here one episode you
are awesome I mean you're
unbelievable I just love this character
already I'm sad there's only one more
episode with him I'm like no I want more
um where are you earlier yeah but you
have this um but here's the thing when
it comes out of if you see what Dante
Basco looks like you know he's Rufio you
see pictures of him nowadays and he he
looks pretty much the same I mean you
know you needs a bit older bay looks
about the same you can still see that
voice coming out of them
and it fits so even this is an older
person nothing else goes well I guess 93
and he was yeah I mean so obviously you
know people that age can have that boys
and he plays a lot of kid characters but
he's older he can add that voice uh and
it's totally possible to have people
that look older at uh for whatever HAP
sort of higher voices Mike Tyson was an
example you brought up yeah somebody
brought up on my facebook when I
mentioned it it was like well look at
Mike Tyson you know he he had a release
sort of lighter voice for somebody who
was a huge boxer and I you know but I
mean the one thing is generally society
kind of made fun of Mike Tyson so maybe
it's distracting if not to his face
though um yeah I mean well no no I'm not
saying society's right but there is this
thing where I don't think they had to
make I wrote a kid but I think they made
him look like he's
to me he looks like he's 40 yeah there's
no kinetic design I feel like the design
they should have gone with would have
been closer to something like Mach Oh
early 20s or even if it just like he's a
general so you don't want to go bad like
maybe 30 or something but and some of it
is I think the lines on the jaw it's a
very chiseled jaw they they gave him
extra lines like they do Tenzin older
Avenue yes we're not saying that people
can't you who look like that can't sound
like that I mean here's the thing we see
like we see men that sound like women we
see women that sound like men
yes that's gonna happen but at the same
time you I think now it's a little
distracting when you say to phone is
ringing go shut off that phone I will
finish the thought so bottom line what
we're saying is that voice is still
unbelievable the design we don't feel
quite matches the voice like like other
versions that they've done or as much as
it could have I think you can totally do
an adult voice an adult an adult design
and still have that voice come out
because it is an adult voice but it's
still like my heard on say Moscow I'm
like great but I was like whoa didn't
didn't expect that speaking of voices
I'm actually losing mine um I think the
issue is it just ends up being
distracting in an unnecessary way and
none of that is um Dante Bosco it to me
it's just he still owns a he's still a
believer came up with the character
design now maybe it was a last-minute
switch maybe they were gonna go with
some other voice actor and they're like
dude why don't we just get down to
Moscow and they were like all right well
we've already got this character design
like I have no idea what went down it
just it just doesn't quite sink up as
well as it should I think it should be
maybe more of a mock Oh character design
you know didn't have to be a carbon copy
of Zuko but yeah there's just something
about it that it just doesn't click with
me you know and I I know it's a tire but
I mean there's one two angles like we
has head down he looked a little younger
it's ER like all the bearing is it okay
there's a great example where he looks
up or something and they removed the
extra lines that gave him some of the
more sunken job ones that look more like
Dante Basco
that when they smooth out the face and
did it from a distance I'm like okay go
with that character design I can see
that like similar looking face not too
different but they just it took about
ten years off and I'm like I feel like I
could see this working now yes
so yeah I mean you know we're talking
about there so um yeah you know got
still great episode mostly the backstory
which is very ballsy to do the
second-to-last episode have it be mostly
a back story I don't but I thought that
was very clever because when it ended
I'm like whoa like that Betsy McVeigh
I'm like ooh I have been watching that
for a long time haven't I the back story
so um I I don't exactly know where it's
going might the two things I can guess
where I would like it to go again
doesn't mean it'd be best but I would
like it to go
one is I like a Monda not I think
they're hinting at this that he doesn't
he's not scarred or anything cuz it
sounds it makes it sound like I already
sort of made up the backstory like you
know Bender's didn't kill the mother or
whatever he said um and then the other
thing I would like to see we saw Glynn
get the power taken away the bending
taken away and I like that a mod does
not kill them after doing that cuz he
you can like tar like said he's it's a
lie but he also really believes in his
cause so it's like that's all he's
looking to do so I like that he takes
away the bending a you're one of us
nowadays everybody stands by the cause
what I would like to honestly see with
this argument going on with all the
ethical stuff I would like to see this
actually end with Korra giving the
bending taken away and I don't know if
they're gonna do that I don't never
gonna do that and like you'll have it be
taken away but then just give it back or
something it kind of like what they do
with avatar with ain't dying and I
coming back or whatever but with this
argument going on between the two and
trying to say no no side is right no
side is wrong I would like to see I
would like to see them really go to the
next step with that I mean you see all
these when lose it when Lin loses her
bending it's like holy like you
know that's really sad but let's see
them move beyond that and let's see what
happens after they and I think with the
Avatar doing that showing it to
or beyond the bending that would be
really fascinating and I don't know if
they're gonna go that route but that
would be really really cool um yeah that
would be I won't see a thing I'm not
telling you what's happening okay so I
mean bottom line it these avatar ended
on incredible note and it looks like
this is building up to an incredible
note um I just curious what they're
gonna do now you know sir went to come
on let's get this story going at two
just like I wholly ship what's gonna
happen max it's like they say way back
ah
now my phone's going goddamn it you know
you you mentioned this a couple times
now in this review I think you're
forgetting how the first season of
Avatar actually kind of got a little
meandering and you know I well I talked
about this before though it can it can
meander it's okay if you're using that
time to craziest characters I don't see
this is that much worse like no no no
okay okay issue with the story here no
act that I don't I didn't feel the
characters in cores world again
tensions world fine perfect the
characters in Cora's world
I don't think worth strong enough to
keep your interest in there like avatar
did and that's why I'm realizing with
this now is that that's what they were
trying to do they're trying to have the
sort of nice playful stuff and then we
get to the serious stuff it's just all
serious stuff which is fine because it
builds up to it but I didn't feel was
strong enough to keep the attention like
how avatar did so those are in my issue
and why I was like get the story going
but actually I realized it wasn't that
had to do works for me but then again I
actually watch sports and enjoy hey it
broke ending was a real thing that maybe
I would watch it but even then I
probably started to get a little part
yeah watch it here what do you mean with
I was just happy that a man came in and
busted up okay if someone said you want
to see Lord of the Rings for basketball
it's like you go see Laura the Rings
well okay here's some basketball it's
gonna take up like two hours of it I
came to see welcome for ratings
they just take frodo scrunchy see you
watch that no no it once they do that to
maybe the little final affair if they
start throwing the fire around like one
okay so one episode left man uh I'm
excited on I'm curious to see where this
is all gonna go and I like that it's
really come it's come around down I'm
excited again I'm just as excited as I
was with avatar so I'll give it away
the trees are behind it damn it that's
well as Mickey Mark Wahlberg ain't so
bad but to twist